can win it that's the first in this  overtime ball out of bounds now probably  is guarding anthony davis so let's see  what the lakers what set they run  with 14 on the 24. see schroeder was 17.  the official was 17 and that was the  biggest lead  for the lakers tonight 17. and they let  it slip away lebron with five to shoot  lebron holds on to a tough shot on its  way  down it goes the king  with a giant three  still a minute and 17 to play here as  lebron  he may be a little fatigued  but he had enough in his legs to elevate  over brumbly  and knock down a big three-pointer  lebron's going to be deliberate with it  jeremy grant playing defense picked by  switching everything seems to be in slow  motion right now lebron another three  yes he's got it again  boy look at lebron i like the way he  acted after he made it though  as if he's done it before i think he has  you